so as the process of growth growth
globalization and poverty reduction
rolled on people in rich countries or at
least the educated Elite in rich
countries who knew about it looked at it
with delight
in the educated Elite I include
International organizations such as the
World Bank and other development
agencies and Foundations as well as
readers of the mainstream press
and most governments of rich countries
and me
but not everybody in the rich World Was
So Satisfied
after 1970 growth in the rich country
slowed markedly
many people struggle to be better off
than their parents
for them the expectation of progress
that each generation had been and would
continue to be better off than the
previous generation was failing them
one reason is that low-skilled jobs and
flourishing cities have become less
available than once was the case
and the cities have become more
expensive
the jobs that were lost were less
skilled jobs but the better jobs that
were available were high skill jobs
people without a four-year college
degree without a ba were increasingly in
trouble
I will talk in a minute about the many
reasons for the increasing division for
people with and without a ba but I want
first to show you some evidence of just
how badly hurt they have been
capitalism in America today has stopped
working for the two-thirds of the
population who do not have a four-year
college degree
here are a few of the most important
facts participation in the labor force
for those without a ba has fallen as
have their real wages
both participation and wages rise in
good years and fall in bad years but
Rises have never taken them back to the
previous High
even when working class wages were doing
well in the months before the pandemic
they were below what they'd been at any
year in the 1980s
some have argued that these Americans
are lazy and no longer want to work but
if that were true wages of low-skilled
workers would be rising not falling it's
the jobs that are Vanishing and with
them the wages that allowed their
parents to have a good middle class life
and it's not just material well-being
marriage rates have fallen dramatically
non-marital childbearing has risen many
children live apart from their father's
communities are failing too with church
going declining and millions of
working-class men detached from any form
of institutional support worst of all is
what has happened to their health
more than a hundred thousand Americans
are dying of drug overdoses every year
these are counted as accidental deaths
but the drugs they were using did not
get into them by accident and so there's
always an element of self-harm
suicides themselves has also been rising
rapidly as of deaths from alcohol abuse
these are the deaths that Anne case
who's sitting here and I called deaths
of Despair in our book and almost all of
the increase in deaths of Despair since
the late 1990s has been among people
without a college degree